in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I helped some thankful developers
come to term with resident instances is
their performance cup half full or half
empty stay tuned to find out I was
attending a meet-up last week where I
was approached by some developers at a
company called think tanks a non-profit
whose goal is to improve the quality and
frequency of thanks given to people and
organizations they were a great group of
folks who built their service on App
Engine and had already done all of the
cold boot optimization that we could
possibly talk about still they were
seeing issues when sudden traffic came
in their problem was that the app
traffic was extremely bursty they would
go from zero users for hours to suddenly
thousands and in those situation
instances were legitimately being called
booted causing a delay in overall
performance while that instance was
being created the latency of think tanks
was taking considerable hit anytime a
new instance was being booted up so
besides just adjusting the scheduler to
boot up less instances it looks like
they needed something stronger to handle
sudden spikes in traffic there was
really only one thing left to suggest
them resident instances as I talked
about before the app engine serving
algorithms are constantly deciding on
whether it's better to cure a request or
spin up a new instance this takes into
account a significant number of factors
to decide when this should happen if
your cold boot time is significant then
during extreme spikes in traffic request
latency will suffer as those requests it
longer in the work queue before being
serviced this could flood your
application with a huge amount of
start-up costs and delay the entire
system significantly this is where
resident instances come in a resident
instance is one that stays alive 24/7
and only receives traffic under a very
specific situation while a new instance
is booting up basically resident
instances are spare instances while a
new instance is booting up they handle
the excess load that a new instance
would be handling once it's up and
running the traffic is sent to the new
instance and the resident one can go
back to waiting around which is really
important because it means that user
requests won't be subject to sudden
spikes and latency that come from cold
boot performance which is exactly what
I saw when we change the min idle
instances flag of think thanks to one
once the new request load came in it was
handled by the existing instance so that
latency didn't shoot through the roof
while the new one was booting up the
takeaway resident instances are the key
to rapid scale and not having your user
perception of latency be impacted but
after playing around with resident
instances a bit sync thanks notice that
there seemed to be a +1 tax involved in
situations where traffic was lower than
normal basically if no one had been
using their application for a while a
sudden burst would cost two instances
the idle instance as well as the new
instance being spun up but for
infrequent traffic that really wasn't
what they needed think thanks was
wasting an infant's an alternative
solution came from a Google+ post where
a community member described a similar
problem his startup process might take
multiple seconds in order to fill a
database but rather than using resident
instances he created and used a cron job
to ping the instance and keep it alive
indefinitely when we tried this on think
thanks we saw pretty much what we
expected in the lowest volume setting
this setup allowed their back-end to
keep from spawning a new instance when
it didn't need to happy with their
latency improvement the think thanks
folks finish their meetups provided
pizza and it went happily along their
way afterwards
I talked to a few App Engine experts who
wanted to make it very clear that
there's two very distinct and separate
use cases here if you have a high
frequency lots of instance churn
scenario and a slow cold boot time then
resident instances are your best bet
however if you have a low frequency
traffic with occasional bursts in a slow
cold boot time then keeping it always
cron instants around is ideal since you
can handle the initial traffic load
gracefully with a lower number of total
instances the downside to both of these
situations is that these persistent
instances come at a cost you're
basically paying for an instance to be
alive 24/7 which could add significant
cost to your operating budget which is
like why I like to say that you should
always carefully balance your trade-offs
before making decisions to go forward
with any performance improvements and to
understand what types of trade-offs
there are make sure to check out the
rest of the Google Cloud Atlas videos
because when it comes to your users
every millisecond counts